entire life has been one of subsistence
one of 12 children she remembers going
to bed with an empty stomach
my family struggled often we didn't have
enough food sometimes we ate once a day
sometimes nothing at all it was shameful
at times I went to bed hungry so my
younger siblings could eat
not much has changed Sylvia is eight
months pregnant and unemployed her
husband is employed as a bus assistant
but she says she struggles to feed
two-year-old Gail
his salary isn't enough for even one
person we spend the two hundred dollars
he makes on food and Necessities for my
son no clothes or anything else Silvia's
story is a familiar one among indigenous
families living high up in the Andes
region of Chimborazo
most make less than half the national
minimum wage of 480 dollars a month
Ecuador suffers from chronic levels of
malnutrition among children indigenous
communities in remote areas are
especially vulnerable
Charities say the covid-19 pandemic and
soaring inflation have worsened the
situation
four out of every ten children under the
age of two suffer from chronic
malnutrition and with it come growth
issues and learning issues this problem
is much worse in rural areas and we
believe the number has doubled since the
pandemic
the rising cost of living led to weeks
of protest by indigenous communities in
June
since then president Guillermo lasso has
pledged to spend 350 million dollars a
year to improve health care in basic
services
but 2023 is expected to be tough for
Ecuador as the government has imposed
austerity measures to tackle the budget
deficit giving families like Sylvia's
little hope of ending the Vicious Cycle
of hunger Alison rampieti Al Jazeera